[Music]
before we continue I'd like to give a
shout out to the sponsors of this video
blade X Lord blade X Lord is a
free-to-play 3d real-time command battle
RPG made by the same staff who worked on
Final Fantasy Chrono Trigger and more
now I personally liked its exhilarating
gameplay and how easy to play it is
cinematic cutscenes draw you into the
expansive story and harmony of sound and
visuals give it a very very realistic
feel so what are you waiting for check
the link in the description and download
blade X Lord now now when we think of
anime we usually think of a lot of
intense action and drama most memorable
moments in anime history are born out of
heat and adrenaline it's either that or
the tears that refuse to stop on the
other side of the spectrum anime can
also be the source for some of the most
simplest joys in life a comfortable way
to unwind and relaxed after a tiring day
especially during troubling times like
now now while I admit that I also
include a couple of fast paced high
action titles in this list I think that
these are some of the nice comfy shows
that you can consider when you want to
unwind and relieve your stress a little
bit a lot of these are comedies and a
couple of them are even downright
wholesome and heartwarming anyway let's
have some fun together now shall we
[Music]
food Wars probably doesn't need any
introduction for most of you one look at
the show as well as the discussions
around it will probably tip you in with
the show's appeal well for those who
aren't familiar with the show food Wars
also known as shokugeki no souma star
soma an aspiring chef working for his
father's restaurant he has dreams to
make it big but as always the road ahead
is tough things get tougher when his
father's restaurant closes sending him
to Todd Sookie Culinary Academy there he
takes on new challenges in the form of
shokugeki high stakes cooking show downs
that put his mettle to the test who
could say no to humorous moments
interesting characters and a healthy
dose of fanservice come for the
fanservice stay for the nice story
charismatic characters and amazing food
showcase that sums food wars are just
about right don't you think music tea
cake and a group of cute girls that's
the face of the anime that
revolutionized the industry as the last
decade began it's a no-brainer that Kay
on one of the most influential
slice-of-life anime out there would make
it to this list Kay on tells the story
of Yui an eager yet lost high school
student looking for a club to join in a
twist of fate she stumbles upon the
school's light music club a club on the
verge of disbandment due to the lack of
members lack of experience aside Yui and
her friends look to one day make it big
to perform in the ever famous Budokan
thus begins her journey into this bright
new world an adventure full of twists
and lots and lots of cake and tea but
it's not all fun and games in between
tea parties and goofing around K on does
have its share of dramatic and emotional
moments many manly tears were shed
during the finale of both seasons why
not take some time to relax unwind and
watch the show that started it all
eighth place on the list is haven't you
heard I'm Sakamoto of being popular at
school it just isn't easy as if if you
need further proof just our sakamoto
constantly being the object of jealousy
isn't an enviable position to be in but
if there's anyone capable of overcoming
it and making the other guys look like
pathetic losers it's none other than the
master of suave there's really just
something with how Sakamoto does things
some court is sophisticated while others
would call it sub
whatever it is though he does think so
fabulous you've got to wonder if you
would get his comeuppance someday take
it from me you better give it up or you
jealous guys
Sakamoto will foil your plots one after
another and come out looking as
confident as ever stood up to the task
how about watching his classroom
misadventures for yourself and laugh
your heart out in amazement at the
master of suave Sakamoto listener or ng
critic ah you know watching Somali and
the forest spirit recently made me
realize how wholesome some anime can be
in terms of showing love care and growth
spliced with the joy of parenting it
also made me remember this show that
told its story in kind of the same vein
actually while Somali is set in a
fantastic world of fairy tales this show
a soggy drop takes place in our world
after losing his grandfather 30 year old
Daikichi goes home and meets a young
girl named Rin now much to his disdain
the little girl finds herself an object
of scorn from the family all thanks to
the fact that she said grandfather's
illegitimate daughter so distraught at
this treatment Daikichi resolves to take
the child in and raise her despite not
exactly looking like the most qualified
person to do this sort of job in a
change of pace from the usual quick
paced action
fanservice or comedy that common people
have come to know anime for whose sake
drop takes us on an enriching journey
about growth family and Parenthood
yep Aion is not the last cure any show
on the list as we proceed with our next
entry Nietzsche job now how do I
describe nichijou well let's just say
that it's a light-hearted comedy
featuring the antics of a trio of
friends at a couple more quirky
characters and you have on your hands
the recipe for a wild comedy that will
surely satisfy your cravings but some of
this out of world fun the only anime can
deliver it's a slice of life anime that
takes pride in its simplicity and
outrageousness but it more than makes up
for it with fun characters a lack of
restraint when it comes to creativity
and sheer silliness that's sure to get a
few chuckles out of you in short
nichijou is just insane and that's not
to be taken negatively it seems to be
this comedy where pretty much everything
goes it's this kind of insanity that
some people could be looking for in
order to loosen some Thai screws brought
about by stress and heave off those
heavy burdens and if that's the case you
should give nichijou a shot if you so
please
[Music]
we have a well beloved classic mushishi
at number five in a world full of mushy
nature spirits ginkgos what can be
called a mushishi special people who
have the ability to interact with these
spirits unassuming these spirits take
the form of things from the natural
world which include rainbows swamps
microbes you name it while neither good
nor evil these spirits do cause a couple
of inconveniences for people and it's up
to ginko to resolve the problem they
cause in a twist from the usual anime
method of resolving conflicts like this
ginkgo doesn't take to battle instead
the series is really mellow and well
paced and the spirits are dealt with
through understanding violence is
usually the last resort in this
thought-provoking show that can be
compared to a docudrama while the
premise might sound formulaic no two
cases are too similar and following
ginkgos journey with each episode does
open some nice insights on human
relationships overall mushishi is an
easygoing show that brings forth a
breath of fresh air with its refreshing
take
[Music]
next we have barakamon life seems so
good for say Xu Honda living the dream
life as a calligrapher his life seemed
to be on an upward trajectory that's
until he loses his cool like how some
accomplished people do when facing
criticism was that punch worth it well
losing your status and getting XR to the
Gotoh Islands near Kaew she certainly
isn't however I'm a firm believer of
seeing beauty in a lot of things and
surely Honda can agree after he meets
the colorful villages and starts growing
as a character through interacting with
them the islands are nowhere near the
peaceful countryside that everyone would
expect and its quirky inhabitants are
far from the most ideal neighbors
someone like Honda can ask for
regardless learning to deal with them
may be just a lesson that master
calligrapher needs who knows maybe it's
even here the Honda can finally find his
own original style a nice good old
turnaround that you think
maybe your idea of relieving stress
during these times is a dose of energy a
rush of adrenaline
if so then take to the skies with saman
and garner and relieve their glorious
fight against the world once again what
else can I say about Gurren Lagann has
not already been set by others its
reputation speaks for itself and one
glance at the show can easily tell you
what to expect I'd say that ttg ELLs are
not more than what it seems on the cover
sure it has no shortage of wild and
crazy action but it's also a story that
will take you through a rollercoaster of
emotions and mind-blowing heroism when
it comes to adventures that transcend
time Chronicle the birth of a hero and
shower you with impressive visuals few
would come close to Gurren Lagann its
mecha madness like you've never seen
before and if you're up for some super
robots make sure to put this one as your
top priority
[Music]
for our number two entry it's time to
enter the world of games in no game no
life dis bored a fantasy world where
everything is decided by high-stakes
games is a gamer's dream paradise if
that's not enough to convince you dis
boards got cat girls elves pretty angels
who would take your head off at the
first chance if not for the rules by the
way and the one true god of games what a
dream world would that be for Sora and
she wrote to gamer prodigies in the real
world who were rescued from their
mundane everyday lives into the world of
games guided by Tet the god of games the
siblings seek to unite the races of dis
board and ultimately defeat God and
become the new rulers of the realm no
Gabe no life takes the tropes and the
fanservice of the power fantasy light
novel and turns it up into overdrive if
you're an avid fan of overpowered
characters a charismatic cast lots of
fanservice
and a couple of laughs along the way
you'll have a fun ride with this one did
I also tell you that the show has more
an amazing soundtrack - where do we
start with Gorna Suba for starters I'd
say that it's one of the best istic I
titles that the recent boom has offered
to us instead of being the usual power
fantasy or the revenge story on Asuma
takes the initiative to pretty much be
all about comedy having a cast of
hilarious trolls makes things that
little bit funnier joined Kazuma in his
new life along with useless God as 2016
explosion girl and everyone's favorite
masochist as they go on a quest to
defeat this world's demon king and
instead of going straight on this grand
quest it turns out that these people
will have to first contend with the
everyday man's greatest enemy living
expenses fun days await and you'll spend
hours on end laughing at the
misadventures of Kazuma and the gang if
you're looking for meme faces hilarious
overreactions quirky characters and plot
developments that will tickle your funny
bones while satisfying that Issyk I
craving corners uber is a must watch so
there you have it ten titles that will
help you relieve stress and give you a
good night's rest I'm sure that you guys
have lists that look quite different
from mine on this topic and I'd love to
hear from you about that sharing is
caring and let's all stay strong
together through thick and thin for more
content and anime recomm
Dacians I very much welcome you to be a
part of the family and hit that
subscribe button and like button for
more updates on top 10 content in days
to come don't forget to check out our
sponsors new game blade X Lord legs in
the description I'll see you next time
on Vinnie tube
[Music]
you